let me jump to we got we got a lot of
stories we got to go through but maybe
the most important one right now in this
context is this story from business
insider
democrats spend over 1 million dollars
to boost dan cox the trump loyalist and
2020 election denier who just won the
gop primary for maryland governor
literal conspiracy it's a literal
conspiracy
the democrats have a scheme
to put money
into trump supporting candidates who
they then come out and say are an
existential threat they are scheming to
manipulate the american people
freaking them out but funding it's it's
it's a false flag this is literally the
democrats engaging in a false flag this
is going look let's say the democrats
are right trump supporters are an
existential threat to this country
trump's candidates and maga candidates
they're funding them and propping them
up some are winning their primaries the
idea is we'll beat them in the primary
and if you don't and even if you do they
gain followers from you helping them
regardless they're not going to go away
so if the democrats are right it's a
threat they are literally funding it and
if the reality is they're not a threat
democrats are engaging in a false flag
operation on the american people via
politics to seize power
okay fine that's not a coup attempt
that's something dastardly at the very
least do you know who's warning them
against this mitt romney he's telling
them this is this like stupid strategy
you shouldn't do this i believe hogan
even came out and said like we are yeah
he was saying we're having democratic
interference in our election i mean
hogan has called cox a uh uh q a on
whack job i believe is the quote he is
not a fan at all but he is also not
looking you know for a guy who's built
his reputation on being able to work
with democrats in a state he doesn't
want this organization coming in and
messing with maryland i mean they were
they were actively putting this out uh
you know kelly schultz had sent out
multiple email campaigns i'd got them
say like listen like this is what's
happening
and for me i was actually i've talked i
talked about it several times today like
i i am still
mind blown
and people you know they were talking
about like one of my friends like he's
gonna put god and country back into
you know the the schools and i'm like no
he's not he's he's in maryland he's out
democrats outnumber you two to one and
the independents in maryland aren't
going to lean that far right in in my
opinion maybe i'll be absolutely crazy
but the guy they're putting him up
against i don't know if you know
anything about wes moore
but wes moore won uh the top 40 under 40
very important people shaping the future
of maryland when i won it he wrote a
book called the other wes moore
he's a i'm almost positive he's a combat
veteran but i know he's definitely a
veteran he
was from baltimore
went he's a a best-selling author you
know
his book is interesting he's a handsome
fella you know tall and handsome don't
bring that up
he's gonna i make one gaff and then i'm
joe biden you know he's gonna
he in in baltimore and in maryland he's
gonna he's gonna chew dan cox up check
out the uh the new york times uh data 62
reporting from the democrat side and
they're already up about 140 000
uh votes
so
you know look the question about whether
or
not
democrat maryland
goes republican i'm not super worried
about that dan cox won by 16 points good
for him
i don't see kelly schultz winning either
i mean the turn on the republican side
wasn't that high the bigger issue is
democrats
and their the schemes the manipulation
on the american people look did you
really think maryland regardless of this
would become a republican state i didn't
think it would become a republican state
i person this is and i i know kelly
and maybe there's some bias there but
i genuinely think that she had an
opportunity coming behind hogan where
the state had improved as much as it had
and i believe she was a commerce
secretary or labor secretary one of the
two
and i thought she could get independence
and could and again with the sentiment
being as much against biden as it is
that she stands a very strong
probability at this year i literally
said if if you're going to win this was
the year for you to win right
i think she had a shot and still was
going to be a fight dan cox
i'll do i'll owe you 20 push-ups i mean
i i i get that too
but she couldn't even muster it's like
if you can't get enough support from
your own party
i don't see how she could win look i i
i
if you can't convince republicans to
vote for you you think you'll convince
independents i suppose i just don't know
and i think maryland's a weird state for
republicans because basically all of one
side of it the the three western
counties want to leave they don't want
to be involved anymore they want to go
join west virginia they sent letters to
west virginia being like please we'd
like to go and west virginia was like
we'll have you just you have to ask
baltimore and baltimore is like can't
hear you stop asking that i don't think
they would do that because then what
would happen if there was all of a
sudden just a massive migration of parts
of states like they literally just start
swapping and changing they should
it's not a bad idea save the country in
my opinion the county state of jefferson
the county under um the eastern
panhandle in west virginia it's part of
virginia has winchester virginia in it
in its constitution if i'm remembering
correctly a west virginia state senator
told me this they have a bylaw in there
that
when west virginia seceded they left it
so if they decide later they're
frustrated with virginia they could
leave so that still stands they could
like file out and be like we don't want
to be here anymore that's not true for
the three counties in maryland but it is
interesting that there are these places
saying we don't look like where our
capitals are we are not represented by
our values we're we're in western
maryland and it is moga country
you go to the grocery store outside of
frederick and brunswick and it's like
trump trump signs any everywhere and it
gets more intense as you keep driving
through the panhandle but you right but
you go into frederick and then the trump
flags turn into rainbow flags and what's
crazy is about that is and we were
actually talking about this earlier is
like a republican
even when because frederick flipped the
year that i ran it flipped blue right
and there was a big conversation about
whether or not it was going to stay that
way based on the migration from
montgomery county up
but what's what's crazy about it is why
does that happen in just the city like
everything else is absolutely red but
this little small city that we have
it instantly morphs to where it's
democrat
and then it's all people coming in
and what's crazy about it is people
leave moko because they don't like moko
and then they turn frederick into moko
people leave california and go to
austin because they didn't like
california but you turn austin into
california and it's like because they
don't they don't understand
they don't understand how they cause the
problem the snowflake doesn't blame
itself for the avalanche
simply put joe rogan moves from you know
california to texas like texas will be
better and then everyone says yeah but
but i like joe's opinions and then it's
like but joe has staff and joe has
industry around him and the industry is
woke and left so if joe rogan comes to
austin sets up a comedy club which he's
doing he's going to attract woke
leftists from california who aren't
going to have those opinions he's going
to attract their sound producers and
their stage managers and their taxi
drivers and their restaurant tours and
then
texas turns democrat kind of
colonization
yeah it kind of feels like they're
colonizing but to be fair there is a
cultural influx into texas which is
actually turning it fairly purplish like
purple leaning red and i'm hearing like
in austin
it's it's it's like kind of kind of blue
but people there are fairly anti-woke
which is surprising not completely but
i'm hearing i'm hearing that at least
from a lot of people and what i'm
hearing from some of our friends who
moved austin it's because they're moving
there so maybe it is a good thing me i
like west virginia because it's already
like the second most trump supporting
state in the country with like 86
percent trump support
not the entire state every county went
red
yeah i mean i i don't i'm not saying
trump is a god emperor or anything like
that but i would rather be surrounded by
people who will leave me alone than
people who won't simply put i like west
virginia because it's culturally purple
like it was such a blue state for such a
long time and it's changed to being read
now i mean i think it is i said this
before but it's a marker of the fact
that the parties are changing but the
people's values aren't necessarily
they're not being interpreted or
projected by the parties the way they
were back in the day
um and i i don't know i think that
you'll see that there are states that
turn blue because of migration but
you'll see states that turn purple
because they're not represented equally
by the two-party system good point you
were saying earlier danny that you
thought that like uh
that um
oh i think i
lost my thought there oh that rhino you
don't like the term rhino dino
republican know republican only and what
you're saying hannah claire is like that
the people aren't being represented by
the part there's too many disparate
ideas to represent have one party
represent them there should be lots of
different parties at this state at this
point i think
because people are rhinos they're they
say the republican because it's one or
the other you got to pick one but your
identity is not it doesn't fall in line
with them well there used to be the term
like blue blood democrat right
which was a blue dog democrat or
whatever it is but like it's like
back then like you were like kind of how
i look at myself like i don't want you
spending my money you know what i'm
saying i don't want you in my life but i
don't care what you do in your life like
knock yourself out it doesn't bother me
at all like if you want to hug trees hug
trees i'm cool with that
but that's gone now and what i can't
understand is how the parties
continuously switch back and forth as to
who's who you guys were talking about
the other day where like now the now the
republican party is becoming like the
blue-collar
working person right where that was the
democrats for a long time like his blue
collar unions the whole nine yards so i
i mean one point time democrats had the
kkk you know what when were we how do
you how does that switch happen i don't
think it ever switched
really yeah i don't
yeah i don't think so
uh
there's there's a whole bunch of
articles and many have written their
thesis on how the parties which never
happened but i think
if you look at the democrats today and
you look at the democrats in the 50s and
go back you're like their policies had
this similar results across the board
it was just
i mean it is what it is well those
places like baltimore like how do you
blame republicans and democrats have
been in charge there for what and
chicago and how do you blame uh the
right for police brutality or you know
they march in new york city but they
keep voting for these people to keep
doing it then protest the people they're
voting for they talk about racist cops
yo you live in a democrat stronghold in
new york where democrats are appointing
the racists and so i'm like it's not
changed it's the same thing they just
need the pr push to claim it did
i look at the policies democrats are
acting look at this california they
tried to repeal their civil rights
provision from their state constitution
that's the democrats for you you know
it's funny right now
i was like i was po i was trolling on
twitter and i put something like
uh someone commented about
abortion
and um denial of personhood rights and i
said yeah well you know who else wanted
to deny personhood rights and i was
going to put the confederacy and then i
was like
that was also the democrats oh wait and
i was like oh wait
the democrats back then denied persona
they denied today you know look you want
you want to issue a moral statement on
abortion fine that's what i'm saying i'm
saying the left is inherently of
opposing personhood rights for the
unborn
it was the democratic party that opposed
personhood rights for slaves
the republicans wanted civil rights and
constitutional rights for everybody so
you think the democrats just
for literally the entire time with the
united states just have a better pr team
well i don't know about a better pr team
i think they had a worse pr team in the
civil war
everyone that you had you had to think
what
almost three times as many union
soldiers fighting against them yeah so
uh i think maybe later on they started
to figure out maybe in the past several
decades they learned control of
institutions was was power they needed
to seize it
you know i take a look at a lot of the
you know we talked a bit about this the
other day you take a look at
aoc pretending to be handcuffed
and it's just like manipulation for
power oh she actually said something
about that said that if it was just
safer yeah you're supposed to keep them
down and back because otherwise if your
arms are flailing they might say that
you're resisting a rest oh come on i
really wanted the headline on our site
to be aoc poses in handcuffs in front of
capital because it was just like such a
moment she clearly decided that was the
way it was supposed to be but is
anything less impressive than getting
being a congress person getting arrested
where there's absolutely no real
repercussion against you like
catch and release yeah did she face any
backlash for that from people being like
there are people who are arrested who
don't have the ability to get out of
jail the way you would you know
i wouldn't be surprised if the vote
comes for its own being like your
privilege that's why you got out of jail
yeah whatever then she'd be like but i'm
fighting for you and it's like
look
it is it is undeniable that you have
many democrats today who will publicly
scream racism is bad whereas you had
democrats in the past who would scream
that segregation was good like the
problem is democrats saying racism is
bad is just a mask for them saying
segregation is good democrats are
outright the party of segregation today
and they've always been that's why i'm
like i don't know where that parties
which supposedly happened you can say it
was the 50s or whatever but when you go
to seattle or portland you see the
libraries and they have poc and non-poc
rooms you're like yeah it ain't the
republicans who are calling for that
it's the democrats once again
wasn't there a college where a bunch of
a group of students of color had been
like we want our own dorm we should be
like allowed to have our own space and
it you were thinking like but i thought
this is segregation i thought we had
fought against this they do that
they they i was reading someone's
article about how they have like asian
dorms and black dorms i think it's like
uc the uc system in california
university of california system
and and the answer i think they gave i
could be wrong was like people want this
and i'm like you know
i guess
it doesn't mean you you
make it you know what i mean if if you
know if people choose to live next to
each other i guess there's not really
much you can say if people are looking
for a dorm and you're like that's norm
for your race that's the dorm for their
race it's like that's a that's a bad
idea you should not do that i just
thought it was weird because it's these
institutions that like charge you a
bunch of money to live like this far
away like one arm's length away from the
other person their rooms are so small
you can touch your roommate's bed and
then they're like no but but if people
want to live by race it's fine like they
don't actually care about how people
live how crazy about the money i
remember hanging out at the columbia
dorms in chicago and it's a two bedroom
with i think eight or maybe it was four
or eight people i'm not sure i think it
was four people each room had two bunk
beds in it i had a bunk bed in it for
two beds and they were like it's a
thousand bucks a month to live here and
then i was like you live with three
other people and you spend a thousand
dollars a month why don't y'all just
like i don't know buy a house you got
four grand per month you can go buy a
house not that far away from here and
they're like i don't know will colleges
make it a requirement to live on campus
so that first year they're charging you
and you have to buy whatever the biggest
like food or meal package or whatever
else so they're guaranteeing money i
mean they are not in it for your
personal growth they're in it for their
bottom line college is a scam yep yeah
do they actually make people live on
campus there were people that would
commute on when i was going i i mean
different schools do it different ways
but a lot of schools the first year
first two you're required to live on
campus like a status school where it's
like cool for you to be part of it so
they want to make you have to be you
have to agree to it like community
college no one cares that you're going
you can commute all you want do they
like market it to like families it's
like oh so your student can get adjusted
and be acclimated and like get used to
living away from home like it's a safety
net like they're going to kind of
babysit your kid for you that is cultish
beyond measure i didn't know they were
forcing kids to go stay there with them
while they indoctrinate them i thought
that people could still commute
it's just the first two years when
you're the most vulnerable to
indoctrination
thanks for checking out this clip from
timcast irl come hang out live monday
through friday at 8pm eastern time super
chat we'll even answer some of your
questions if you want to check out the
after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you